loading these tile maps is actually a
pretty complex process so we're going to
walk through it piece by piece first to
parse the JSON you'll notice that we've
actually modified our load function call
to call parse map JSON with the data we
get from our xhr request now the data
we've received from the Internet is
actually a JSON blob the first thing we
need to do is actually called json.parse
passing in the JSON blob to actually
give us an object in JavaScript next
what we'd like to do is to actually
cache some of the values of this new
JSON object inside of the map class
itself so we don't have to keep walking
through and querying that data object
later on the parameters we care about
keeping track of right now are the total
number of tiles across and down in the
Atlas the size of each of those tiles in
pixels and then the size of the entire
map in pixels
now once you've retrieve that data from
our JSON object go ahead and set the
fully loaded attribute to true